- [Narrator] The Honest Company Steps Up.
Everyone I approached was skeptical.
Even my husband, Cash,
thought the idea was too big.
Jessica Alba, co-founder
of The Honest Company.
The Honest Company took it's
one word to the next level.
Not only did co-founders Jessica Alba
and Christopher Gavigan embrace
the one word philosophy,
they named their business
after their one word, honest.
Jessica and Christopher were
disgusted by how unhealthy
many children's products are.
They are laced with toxic chemicals
that haven't been properly tested.
They were making kids and Jessica sick.
She and Christopher got fed up.
So they decided to be the change
they wanted to see in the world.
They launched The Honest
Company to provide non-toxic,
eco-friendly, fashionable, and
affordable products for kids
ranging from diapers to
bath and body products.
They believed in their business
so much that they hired
Jessica's mom to work for them.
They loved their manifestoian
product so deeply,
that they hang them on their wall.
Jessica practices honest
management and the actress
entrepreneur worth over
200 million dollars,
doesn't have her own office.
She sits right along side her team.
They don't test their products on animals.
They test them on their own children.
They give one percent of their revenue
to charity in chemical research.
From their employees, to their suppliers,
they think about the impact
they're leaving on the world.
To reduce their carbon footprint,
everything they make is
produced within 150 miles
of Los Angeles and they
ship ground, not air.
They have unapologetically
high standards in products,
people, and business practices.
Everything they do
has to match up with
their honest philosophy.
The results?
The Honest Company went from zero to
hundreds of millions of dollars in sales.
After three years in business,
the company was valued
at one billion dollars.
They are making money and making
an impact by following their one word.
So I asked Christopher to
share his one word story.
- [Christopher] Early in my
career, I was frustrated.
I was frustrated with the lack of
authentic relationships in business.
I was frustrated when I
saw that everyone would
promise you the world
and then there was no
consistent follow-up.
That's being totally dishonest.
What I found was the levels of
transparency and authenticity
and clarity and willingness
to tell the consumer what was
healthy and safe weren't there.
And I'm thinking, wow, these
are products that we are using
on our bodies, in our
homes, on our children.
We're ingesting them.
How is that possible?
When my business partner Jessica and I
were developing our concept,
we were imagining the world.
Dreaming big and what we wanted in it.
We were thinking about
what's the world we wanted?
I love the beauty of the word, honest.
The simplicity.
To be honest is something
that everyone wants to be.
It's an aspiration as well
as a real life fulfillment.
It's an honor to hold that word.
It's a privilege and it's a duty.
It holds you to a standard
and it drives us forward every single day.
I wanted to challenge ourselves.
To be honest.
What does that mean?
That's a lot to live up to.
I wanted to see if we could do it.
We're constantly, as a
brand and as a company,
pushing ourselves to really
achieve, to be more and more
honest every single day.
Everyone is here to see this
mission and purpose-driven
company fulfill its core goal
and a lot of it is we're
not here to build product.
We're here to educate
a new generation of consumers and parents.
In our core mission, we
don't talk about product.
We talk about what's the change
in the world we want to see
and how do we accomplish that?
You have to align yourself
with what you believe is right.
What I love about us is we
really act from our heart
and if it doesn't feel right,
we're not going to go there.
Honesty is telling people the truth
even though it might be uncomfortable.
It's quality.
It's saying what matters.
It's telling people what you won't do
and what's not inside as
opposed to what is inside.
We're everything from a
baby diaper to shampoo
to fruit and veggie washes to
a range of lifestyle products.
At the end of the day, a
parent just wants to trust you.
I guard that trust.
I safeguard it every single day.
It's the only thing we have.
Our credibility and trust.
I am such a strong, passionate advocate
of keeping that trust and
that level of connectivity
with the consumer and letting them know
we are doing everything
possible every single day
to build and improve
on that level of trust
and connected relationship.